THE SENATE LABOR, PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. WE HAVE
ONE ITEM ON OUR AGENDA TODAY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO START SENATOR
BARRASSO, IF THAT'S OKAY WITH
YOU, YOU WILL BE PRESENTING ON
SB 828. WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM BEFORE WE GET STARTED,
SO, ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS HERE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS HERE. WILK.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. HERE. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO HERE. LAIRD THANK YOU,
SENATOR DURAZZO. YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB 828. AN
EMERGENCY MEASURE THAT MOVES THE
START DATE OF THE HEALTH CARE
MINIMUM WAGE BY ONE MONTH TO
JULY 1ST, 2024. SB 525. AS YOU
RECALL, PROVIDED A HISTORIC WAGE
INCREASE TO MORE THAN 450,000
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, MAINLY
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR, WHO
TAKE CARE OF US, WHO TOOK CARE
OF US AND KEEP OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM FUNCTIONING. IT IS CLEAR
THAT THESE WORKERS NEED THIS IN
ORDER TO HELP SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES. I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
HEALTH CARE EMPLOYERS THAT HAVE
RECOGNIZED THIS AND HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN TO INCREASE WAGES. THIS
BILL REAFFIRMS THE GOALS OF SB 5
TO 5 WHILE ALIGNING SB 5 TO 5
WITH THE BUDGET YEAR, I HAVE
WITH ME FROM SEIU MATT LEGGETT,
WHO WILL SPEAK. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING, MATT, HERE ON BEHALF OF
SEIU CALIFORNIA, WE'RE THE PROUD
SPONSORS OF SB 525, WE TOOK THAT
BILL ON BECAUSE WE HAVE A
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE WORKER
SHORTAGE OF MORE THAN 500,000
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF THAT
NEED. AND THAT WAS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC, NOW THAT NEED IS JUST
GROWN AFTER THE HORRORS OF THE
PANDEMIC, AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE TO DELIVER ON
CALIFORNIA'S CARE, NEEDS OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE THAT IS
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL, BY THE
RECENT LABOR CENTER REPORT FOUND
THAT 75% OF THESE WORKERS ARE
WOMEN OF COLOR, 75% OF THESE
WORKERS ARE PEOPLE ARE WOMEN,
AND 75% ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR, SB
88, AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED,
ALIGNS THE LAW WITH THE STATE
FISCAL YEAR. SO IT MAKES SOME, A
LITTLE EASIER TO ADMINISTER. AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF SB 828.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
OTHER WITNESSES? NOPE. SO WE
WILL GO TO THE ROOM. ANYONE IN
THE ROOM HERE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. HI. GOOD MORNING,
MARK FRUTH, CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HI. GOOD MORNING. CHRISTINA
ALVAREZ. I REPRESENT 20,000
WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SECURITY OFFICERS,
INCLUDING OUR KAISER SECURITY
OFFICERS, ALL THROUGHOUT
SACRAMENTO AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS SARAH. I
WORK AT MERCY GENERAL DIGNITY
HEALTH, ALSO KNOWN AS
COMMONSPIRIT. I'M A
NEURODIAGNOSTIC TECH, ALSO AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF HEALTH
CARE WORKERS HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY AND REGION. WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB 828. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS MARQUETTA WILLINGHAM. I
WORK WITH KAISER PERMANENTE AS A
SENIOR SURGICAL TECHNOLOGIST,
AND I REPRESENT SEIU, UW. I AM
HERE TO SUPPORT SB 828. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME IS
APRIL WHITE AND I'M A CASHIER
RECEPTIONIST AT TRACY KAISER.
AND AS A HEALTH CARE WORKER AND
A MEMBER OF SEIU, UW, I SUPPORT
828. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS KETURA JAMES. I'M A
SENIOR STAFF ASSISTANT AT KAISER
PERMANENTE HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AS A SEIU, UW MEMBER, WE SUPPORT
SB 88. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
MELINDA MCGEE. I WORK AT SOUTH
SACRAMENTO KAISER. I AM A MEMBER
OF SEIU. I'M UAW. I'M A LAB
ASSISTANT AT KAISER, AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT SB 828. THANK
YOU. OKAY. SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, WE'LL MOVE
TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE
OPPOSITION WITNESS HERE? OKAY.
ANYONE WANTING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? OKAY
SEEING NONE. OKAY. WE'LL BRING
IT TO OUR MEMBER. WOULD YOU MOVE
THE RECOMMENDATION? THANK YOU.
SENATOR CORTESE MOVES THE BILL.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY TO THE
AUTHOR, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHENOMENAL WORK AND TO THE
SPONSORS FOR THIS BILL. WE KNOW
OUR WORKERS ARE HURTING. WE KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR US TO
REMEMBER THE PANDEMIC, TO LEARN
FROM THOSE LESSONS, AND TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO RAISE
THE FLOOR FOR THOSE WORKERS. BUT
REALLY, ALL WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA SAW THE YESTERDAY AND
THE NEWS THAT THERE IS AN
INTERNATIONAL TREATY NOW BEING
BUILT AROUND COVID SO THAT WE
PREPARE FOR THE NEXT PANDEMIC.
AND I THINK THIS IS CALIFORNIA'S
WAY OF PREPARING AND ENSURING
THAT WE DO THE WORK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
INTENDED. AND THAT'S MOVING THIS
BILL FORWARD. SO, AGAIN, THANK
YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR DE RAZO,
FOR YOUR WORK. AND WITH THAT,
LET'S MOVE THE BILL. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON SB 828. THE MOTION
IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
BE CONCURRED IN SMALL CUEVAS I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I DURAZO DURAZO I LAIRD.
THIS BILL HAS A VOTE OF 3 TO 0
AND IT IS ON CALL. AND WE WILL
MAKE SURE THE VOTE MEMBERS VOTE
WHEN THEY RETURN. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, AND THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO SHOWED UP TO
TESTIFY TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR RUSSELL.
OKAY, WE WILL GO ON A BRIEF
RECESS AS WE WAIT FOR OUR
SENATOR TO RETURN TO MAKE HIS
VOTE. THANKS.
LABOR COMMITTEE IS BACK IN
SESSION. SENATOR LAIRD, WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE OUR SB 828 OFF THE
ROLL AND HAVE YOU VOTE NOW.
ASSISTANT, WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL? YES ON FINAL ITEM, EIGHT
TWO, EIGHT. THE VOTE IS THREE
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
THE MOTION IS THAT ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
SENATOR WILK. SENATOR LAIRD I
LAIRD I. OKAY. WITH THE VOTE OF
4 TO 0, THAT BILL IS OUT. AND
THAT CONCLUDES OUR COMMITTEE
AGENDA FOR THE DAY.